[Music]
and you will always
subject for today
[Music]
ted cruz is going to be telling you if
we were tomorrow tomorrow we have
technical what's in the what's this
yeah we have ted cruz in the show
tomorrow that's exciting i thought he
was teaching you how to sip
and i know some people are asking me
like hey what's this are you going on a
safari no
i am keeping the heat on until this
election is over it's not over
you never got me down he didn't get me
down sleepy joe
so we have a lot to talk about today uh
more on election irregularities fraud
irregularities
regularities fraud fact checking uh
cardi b we'll be talking about what else
are we talking about today i'm trying to
remember what we're uh we
are talking about oh the vaccine success
yeah
right after the election if only right
before the election people saw that
unemployment fell below seven percent
and that we had a vaccine believable
it's almost like all those dead people
wouldn't have voted
[Laughter]
uh but audio weight is here how are you
doing well i think we have half asian
bill tomorrow and ted cruz talking about
voter stuff going on i'm
excited quarter black garrett how are
you tim from hr hate him uh we have
token owen and we have
gerald a how are you i'm well how are
you are you good i'm doing very well
drinking a lot of wine why are you doing
so well it's just a good day did your
little kid say his first words
uh he's a little young for that was it
really yeah you know what his first
words are going to be
probably mama emancipation why would he
want that
it's a loving family emancipation is
when you leave
you said that isn't emancipation the
same term yeah you can emancipate a
child from their parents
you didn't know that did you you were
thinking slavery of course yeah oh
wow it's always on the breed we let
those get away from us
never again real stain on our history
uh but we have so much to talk about and
listen libra how can you be happy during
this time
uh you know what uh why not yeah
this is incorrect this is a momentous
occasion in history and i am not just
i hope that you are feeling feeling the
groundswell feeling almost like you know
like the violence at a black lives
matter protest that you're feeling that
things are changing right
and not only for president donald trump
uh but for the country
for the entire country as it relates to
election fraud so i do have to eat some
crow because right off the bat yesterday
i was talking
about my time at fox news a little
inside baseball there and then there's a
kid who dies in a hospital bed
oh um that was a babe ruth appointing
not yeah it's like did that happen
i don't know if it actually happened i
know i've never heard to have happened
so he like hit a kid
i'm just picturing like yeah yeah that's
the way it is i'm going to hit that
baseball bat leukemia how do you like it
the famous called the shot he killed the
kids
can someone let me know the chat if that
actually happened i've heard that that
didn't actually happen
i don't think there's evidence of it but
it is claimed that it happened evidence
that he had the clap
okay but let's get to some news that's
important some crow here i don't know
why that term is used because i was
giving you some insight baseball
yesterday about fox news
and i said that neil cavuto was the
nicest person i'd ever met that is still
true
two things can be true at once however
i guess i don't even say however because
he was the nicest person that i've ever
met
thanks chad and uh yesterday he was
being kind of an
[ __ ] because he cut off kaylee
mcinney who by the way
is still still the press president
last i checked and probably will be for
four more years
he cut away from her right as she
started talking about
voter fraud and people are upset about
this and rightfully so i have a
follow-up right after watch what
happened
we want an honest accurate lawful
count we want maximum sunlight we want
maximum transparency we want
every legal vote to be counted and we
want every
illegal vote i just think we have to be
very clear
she's charging the other side is
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to
back that up
i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this i want to make sure
that maybe they do have something to
back that up
but that's an explosive charge to make
the other side is effectively
rigging and cheating now may seem
important but uh some actually believe
this is a glorified pr stunt for
baby geniuses three this time it's
petulant which does seem it's
not outside the realm of possibility
you'll see why you would do that um
big breakout roles i still have my diet
coke from the clearance thomas thing
yesterday
wow this is uh this is a shock buzzer
for joe lewis i don't know joe lewis but
i don't actually shock him it's just a
vibration so animal rights
so you can go screw yourself here's the
thing he says maybe we'll cover her uh
if she brings any evidence so those are
some pretty serious charges
here is you know you do your audience a
disservice when you cut away
from her doing exactly what you're
accusing her of not doing
this is 45 seconds
seconds later allow me to just broadly
review
three points that have happened in
pennsylvania number one
in philadelphia poll watchers who are
legally legally permitted
to be there and observe the vote count
were blocked
from observing the count second article
1 section 4 of the united states
constitution clearly states this the
time
place and manner of holding elections
for senators and representatives
shall be prescribed in each state by the
legislature thereof
that's right the state legislature is
constitutionally the one
making the decision but the supreme
court of the commonwealth of
pennsylvania kathy bookvar and the
democrat tilted
pennsylvania supreme court have
continually disregarded the constitution
making decisions
clearly in the domain of the
pennsylvania legislator
and finally a mere survey of the
were given certain privileges that
voters in red counties were not afforded
the constitution's equal protection
clause requires uniform standards but
democrat election
officials created disparities depending
on where citizens lived
and where they voted in the state now i
don't want to be conspiratorial because
like i said neil cavuto was always very
nice with me and
i hope listen mr cavuto thank you for
the opportunities that you provided me
um i don't know if these orders are
coming from the top down yeah
but how if you are a news agency and you
say well you know those are pretty big
uh
those are pretty big allegations uh if
she offers it and you cut away
how do you think that serves your
audience
this is a con this is an entertainment
show when people say like you're the
only show i watch i go no
watch other shows too
that's bad for example there is no baby
geniuses three that's a lie oh
no no was once referred to as a joke but
that's a movie it's a lie but the fact
that we are providing context on both
sides we own our biases and then we say
by the way this is what both sides are
saying and this is why this site sucks
how does neil cavuto justify that how
does fox news justify that
i'm done with i'm done with this guy
they should definitely issue an apology
he could have made the same statement
and cut away for just a second said
these are pretty big claims let's see if
she backs it up and gone back to it
if to see what social media does and
i'll read later on the exact
fact check that you see on twitter right
every time i listen to npr
when it's not some lesbian funk duo
better music donald trump making claims
of voter fraud uh despite there being no
evidence to the oh well well
you just keep saying i feel like there
was a meeting where they just said let's
just say no evidence
and cut off right before they provide
evidence well there is an assumption
that there cannot be evidence
right the baseline assumption is well of
course she's just going to come out and
talk and just say
blather on about xyz but no assuming
that she won't go on to provide evidence
right is part of an argument right it's
a point of view
your honor i would like to present to
you exhibit ad guilty
let's go for lunch exactly jimmy jackson
and i love how they say a little
overrated is really just a sandwich
mayonnaise mustard there's nothing not
even jelly mustard but you know what i
don't know why i'll pay three times the
price because uh
marketing that's fantastic take that
jimmy johnson
what cnn is saying about the vaccine i
was just gonna say that they say
voter fraud they're trying to push you
into this category
not irregularities not rules being
changed by states they're saying oh
people aren't being fraudulent on their
votes come on that's silly to be fair
donald trump did say voter fraud which i
thought was uh right misstep
but at this point voter fraud yeah i
mean we're passing there's plenty of
irregularities yeah there's probably
something like the winning argument is
irregularities alone
i am this close to calling every single
louder with crowder viewer and everyone
here
to go rent out a time share or apartment
in georgia and voting the [ __ ] out of
those runoffs
[Applause]
close to just doing it but i know that
we would be caught
let's go to cnn really quickly before we
continue the time a potential vaccine
may be more than 90
effective could affect 400 a good
potential right
that same person wow masks physical
distance
when you go out no shutdown just masks
and physical distancing
two and a half people oh here we are
here we are no
shut down when they think it's gonna be
present the good thing is there's no
shutdown wow the good thing is we don't
have to do a shutdown because uh we
we claim to bite in the winter all right
uh
here's something else too actually we
have some uh now we have some breaking
news let's go to reg the bandit
breaking news
[Music]
yeah okay reg the research man this guy
is brilliant
um you have some news for us actually uh
positive news regarding william commonly
known as bill
barr an investigation with voter fraud
right reg
yeah so uh yesterday late we found out
that
the attorney general william barr has
authorized federal prosecutors to pursue
what he calls substantial allegations
of voting irregularities before the 2020
presidential election
is certified okay now what's what's just
breaking this morning
is that the top department of justice
prosecutor richard pilger has resigned
in protest
now isn't he the guy isn't he the guy
who was involved with the lois lerner
irs scandal where they were basically
targeting conservatives
is that why i remember the awful name
pilger
yes yes yes he met with lois lerner uh
you know back in 2010 that early to
discuss
targeting conservatives because they
were mad about citizens united and a few
other things i thought well
how can we how can we get these people
while we'll go through the irs
right yeah okay so good so he resigns so
let it never be said that american
institutions can be politicized
i'm glad he's out and then uh you have
something else too that relates to this
something
our old buddy kevin roose who wrote up
some stories about us
yeah yeah kevin roose if you don't
remember him he was the guy who wrote
the you know the making of a youtube
radical and posted philip defranco's
face next to richard spencer and
everything in the new york times
journalists as you're saying yeah well
he
um tweeted out today that facebook is
absolutely teeming with right wing
misinformation right now oh no these are
all
among the most tin engaged urls on the
platform over the last 24 hours
now the things he shows are that uh
stories covering how a republican in
michigan flips to a winner after a
glitch was corrected what happened
bars investigation michigan holding an
emergency session to investigate voter
irregularities
and uh lastly that there were calls for
georgia's secretary of state to resign
so the funny thing is these are all true
stories yes exactly
misinformation so you know after most of
twitter tells her who's like hey
these are real yeah he has a little
follow-up and he says the tricky thing
for facebook is that
that some of the most viral stories
aren't strictly false
strictly far as strictly false
that's a double negative hedge word uh
but it's it's real it is just the
statement of a [ __ ] let's be honest
they aren't mostly strictly false he's
just saying i don't want people talking
about these things
of course they're happy and that they're
talking it would be nice if you wouldn't
what are we about to say that rich and
he says that they're the problem is that
they're
they're not false but they're feeding a
narrative he doesn't like oh there it is
credibility's not nearly dead it's
really most sincerely dead
i hope that he uh uh just you know
uh finds another line of work oh okay
that was that was pretty tame
well thank you reg we appreciate you
updating us uh
for people who are watching by the way
please do subscribe on um apple podcast
and android for people who don't know
that there are audio versions there
everywhere everywhere
that it's available uh you know i think
spotify too i'm not entirely sure
and do consider joining my club live
club the uh crowder election stream
promo code
still gives you 30 off because this
election is not over still going
not over we're hemorrhaging money
it was my fault but we are here to serve
you and we'll be taking your chat the
reason we don't take chat on youtube is
because
well we don't wanna so um my question
for you as we go into the vaccine first
and then we're going to get into voter
fraud
and i want to know if you guys would
like to see an installment series of
voter fraud state by state because we've
covered it as it's come in
but i almost think that we could do a
30-minute episode a 30-minute
installment on georgia a 30-minute
installment on pennsylvania a 30-minute
installment on michigan a 30-minute
installment on arizona
we could do all of those that you feel
as though you're equipped to deal with
all of them because right now it's like
drinking from a fire hose
here's what you need to know there's a
lot in all of these states
more than in any other election and
that's not just because it's donald
trump
it's because massive unrequested mail-in
ballots
and corruption at the polls so let's be
really clear here any
did anyone hear anyone here ever dispute
the election with uh barack obama and uh
not at all did anyone here ever dispute
the election with uh with uh
barack obama and mitt romney no no did
anyone here dispute the election when
they called it for al gore before it
went to bush no
no i was like ah that sucks i was like
that guy
right yeah yeah yeah that was like a
third grader you're a young
who grows a beard like a 60 year old had
a beard back then but let's go to some
good news
because uh this is something again while
we're talking about fact checking it's
important
donald trump talked about how there
could be a vaccine right how it could be
here before the end of the year
so operation warp speed is what it was
people say what is operation warp speed
what can the president actually do
here's the beauty of operation warp
speed that people miss um
the government can't do so much other
than get out of the way and allow people
to create solutions
right you can't just for example
solyndra you can't just step
in and spend money to make green energy
uh all of a sudden affordable and useful
but what you can do
is step back you can step back and let
elon musk go to elon musk
you can step back and say you know what
let's remove some of this red tape some
of these bureaucracies
everyone everyone said donald trump
rolled back regulations hope you like
your dollar fifty gas yeah
hope you like your vaccine that's coming
down the pike before you carve your
thanksgiving turkey possibly i
exaggerate but certainly before the end
of the year
some of you do christmas hams i'm
canadian we do turkey at christmas
anyway so operation warp speed
has yielded results yesterday the uh
pfizer ceo
um released this information that
there's a coveted vaccine
with a 90 90 uh
efficacy effectiveness rate i don't
necessarily know where they're used
but here you go the pharmaceutical giant
pfizer is reporting early data from its
vaccine trial
that shows it to be more than 90 percent
effective 90
is the game changer 90 now
you are uh what
[Music]
trust me we've been doing all the
research for a long time
on ourselves when you skype me what do
you always do at diagonal
what is that this guy you get to be ceo
i don't want him working with bunsen
burners
hold on the flame is not wind resistant
no no it's just going up
you lie this is our latest bond villain
crooked face
and all of it like all those taglines
are like it looks to me
like maybe you're the one who has
something
that is crooked
looks to me like maybe you didn't quite
go down
the center line
i smell something off
kilter that is the most crooked face oh
short of quentin tarantino but quentin
tarantino's looks more like a muppet
where he went
this is just it's just so asymmetrical
accurate which is of course a sign of
bad genetics so
with the count's voice of course yeah
only he can't count
how many figures am i holding up
why do you always try and trick me and
bring out fake
hand with more than five fingers i catch
you every time
[Laughter]
but that's not the point of this story
donald trump said that you could of
course have the vaccine
within the year and nbc news fact that's
gonna be where we're using a lot today
they fact-checked him
like neil cavuto fact-checked shaylee
mcinniny by not allowing her to present
facts while of course providing none of
his own
interesting and it's uncanny the baby
geniuses resemblance so nbc news
fact-checked
it saying that he would need a miracle
that was remembered he'll need a miracle
to pull this off um and there was also
governor cuomo who said
it was uh it was bad news that it came
during the trump administration and said
that he would work with other governors
to stop the vaccines distribution so
let's just go to a montage remember
donald trump said
hey we might get a vaccine or certainly
an answer on a vaccine we talked about
we were fact checked on this show
before the end of the year this is how
they responded
we're looking to get it by the end of
the year if we can maybe before
we're doing tremendously well how
realistic is this goal i didn't hear
anybody say by the end of the year
was likely or probable as the president
you have two months and we can't let
this vaccination plan go forward
the way the trump administration is
designing it
because biden can't undo it two months
later we'll be in the midst of it
and i'm going i've been talking to
governors across the nation about that
uh how can we shape the trump
administration vaccine plan to fix
it or stop it uh before it does damage
because biden can uh biden can't undo
anything unless it's a six-year-old's
bra
oh you can do it with your
teeth like a cherry step wow yeah
how are you so good at that years of
pregnant
practice do you know i'm just waiting
for the article from cnn that says
something like how to get two vaccines
[Laughter]
so this is again now we have good news
we don't need a lockdown right we're
gonna have a vaccine
and you wanna talk about you wanna ask
can science be politicized you just had
the governor of the
is it the most populated thing is
california new york too second issue
somewhere second or third either way
hopefully because yukon cornelius just
you know axe pick it and push it off
into the ocean
it's out there go find it
um the governor of new york was saying
we will not distribute this vaccine uh
if
if it comes under the donald trump
administration yeah what does that have
to do with science
what the primary for me the litmus test
should be
does the vaccine work right yeah yeah
and this isn't coming from donald trump
by the way
it's coming from also big pharma i guess
we stopped hating them now
right exactly and it's again it's not
donald trump in a lab coat with beakers
backstage like hey let's make some
vaccines no
i would trust you more than to be the
president i go back
and forth and why is my table melting
this always happens right and they're
also admitting that the coronavirus is
not as deadly as they thought
right at the same time they're saying oh
we need a vaccine and we have it we need
you so
they're they're playing trying to play
both sides we have one but let's wait
three months
before we uh put it into hey i hate to
do this honor but wait you see that
ashtray could you
and jam it through my skulls i don't
wanna die here on air oh yeah is there
anything someone can give me that i just
have like a seizure so that i just
become a vegetable because
nothing would nothing would please me
more than breaking the balls of my
family so they'd have to wipe my ass for
the rest of my life
what in the world
[Laughter]
i'm happy i'm optimistic about the
election right really i'm optimistic
about donald trump
but i am furious you're gonna bud dwight
they are they are
i am furious that they actually want to
do this
disservice to the american public as it
relates to
you know what i don't think that covet
is all that i licked popsicle sticks
from people who had cove but still don't
have it i think it's because i smoke
cigars
but i do i care about i have a 97 year
old grandmother yeah yeah
who i love i play romance she talks mad
trash
by the way her husband was the one who
was mayor well city supervisor of
bloomfield township when there was a
flip of 6 000 votes
my roots go deep in michigan yeah
we want people to be healthy so mike
pence tweeted out
walking gi joe look alike really there's
a symmetrical face
that's a complicated symmetry huge news
thanks to the public-private partnership
forged by president donald trump and
pfizer announced its coronavirus vaccine
trial
is effective at preventing infection in
90
of volunteers that's good he was
immediately fact checked immediately
fact check
new york times reporter virginia hughes
screw hugh wrote that pfizer has never
been an opera a part of operation warp
speed and uh then vanity fair ran a
piece saying that mike pence falsely
claims takes credit for pfizer vaccine
is promptly told to f
off and this is where vanity fair
they're doing work what they do is they
take an article
right they find a bunch of random
twitter eggs who don't like mike pence
saying we hate you and then they write a
whole article about how everyone hates
mike pence yeah
look at everybody agrees well everybody
that's a check
turns out the fact checkers were wrong
no
pence was right pfizer he was a part of
operation warp speed and here we go we
have an overlap right there from some
guy who actually blocked me on twitter
so
somebody doesn't even like me they were
a part of operation warp speed they're
trying to
rather than say hey we have a vaccine
that's 90 effective good news americans
they are trying to shout from the
rooftops like the ricolad guy
mike pence lied on a technicality
of the vet help americans media
help americans how about that how about
you how about you
serve the people who pay your salaries
less and less mind you
and it was thanks to this guy and it was
so blatantly wrong that that's the cnn
fact checker the guy who has bent
over backwards to make sure he doesn't
say anything good about donald trump
he's like yeah that's actually no
that's not right they're in the program
where's the factory outside of us
where's the fact checker
checker of new york times hey there have
been stories i've watched on youtube
regarding this which is basically just
someone you know saying mike pence said
this and then he was fact checked right
youtube where do you fact check that
shouldn't you just just put
how hard is it for you just put
underneath those videos uh
pfizer was a part of operation workspeed
pfizer did benefit did work alongside
operation warp speed how about just
making the auto suggested video this
crooked face
pfizer ceo saying we are very thankful
for whatsfeed
how about just that youtube never shows
up
never shows up no it's not are there
rules it's
are there rules applied equally
and this leads to dead america and you
know what we've actually um helped play
it we've actually worked alongside it's
not just government entities with
operation warp speed ourselves we
haven't talked about it a lot we haven't
talked about it a lot right but we've
worked with warp speed uh by repeatedly
testing
previously untested vaccines on brendan
uh and i think yeah
brendan for days on end brendan thank uh
thank you for doing that brendan how are
you feeling uh there in the
cubicle good oh
well you know what brendan thank you for
your service uh to this country
with operation warp speed we really do
appreciate it
oh yeah well you know what listen we are
patriots here
yeah okay that's enough it's just gonna
make america sad okay
i think oh boy i think one of them will
work eventually
i like that kid it's a sacrifice we're
willing to make though you know what we
tested every vaccine on him
other than pfizers oh which looking back
he's the guinea pig
we have the choice yeah he might still
get the coronavirus he might
we might have actually just injected him
yeah i think with kovid he might be the
personification
of the coronavirus and something else
yeah it turns out vaccines are only
supposed to have enough to build
immunity
okay uh we just gave him the full dose
of viruses why would you do that
we didn't know for science we couldn't
know right exactly
google i guess all right we have some uh
election updates
here are any other thoughts on the
vaccine i just think it's hillary i
don't know that you can prove
that they held it until after the
election um because obviously coming out
so
quickly after the election it just looks
like if you're gonna design a game plan
don't do everything that looks so
horribly
wrong like go let's wait a week and a
half after the election yeah well the
sad part
there's something different the sad part
is it's working yeah on the left they're
like well nobody even brought us the
vaccine
you're buying a vaccine joe biden
brought unemployment down to six point
something percent
you're gonna see another jobs report
before joe biden takes office my
prediction is it's going to
i wouldn't even be surprised if it goes
below six yeah it'll definitely be low
six which i think is lower than the
maybe someone can bring it up maybe
register i think the obama
average for his entire presidency was
like seven yeah it was pretty high
certainly it wasn't three and a half no
certainly wasn't three and a half
percent
i don't think americans realize how good
they've had it we had this in canada
they got named
uh prime minister stephen harper and
they avoided the financial uh
the bubble the housing crash because
even though canada is no highways of
socialist health
socialist hellhole right they just said
like hey you know the united states you
know what they're doing over there
they're you know you know the fannie mae
freddie mac you know the dodd-frank all
the stuff
they're uh they're giving houses to
people who can
never pay it back maybe you guys should
try it and the guys in canada said no
[Music]
that was prime minister stephen harper
that was an entire conversation yeah
that was for me he said no why would we
why would we give people
i would give people loans who can't pay
it back and they said
well we got predatory lending going on
here and then stephen harper said what's
pr
did you just say predatory lending to
people who can't pay it back
you're a horrible predator that's like a
shark
only biting fish that will kill them
but yeah when i hear stories of
predators on the news they don't just
hand out money yeah
like a pedophile who just gives you
candy from the van then rather than
inviting you in
he drives away santa claus is a predator
now
hey kid do you like puppies uh yeah sure
i do
well there's a shelter nearby hope you
enjoy it bye bye
here's a free one all that shots are
taken care of right yeah and as the van
pulls away it's just gone and biden's
right behind holding a snickerdoodle
that's a cookie not a dog
don't like them they don't blend them
with snickers now that's for definitely
and anyone who bought them because you
thought they were hypoallergenic
you're an idiot they're not all hypo and
you've taken this is the problem with
the labradoodle
this is the problem with the labradoodle
and the uh what is it golden doodle and
the cockapoodl and all these things
yeah poodles are highest on the
intelligence index with dogs
okay but they also have the worst temper
problems you've combined that
with the high energy of a labrador oh no
so now you've just got an angry
high-energy that's not good monster that
feels like petting a mane of someone
short and curlies and for some reason
you think that's a good thing
yeah when you think about it like that
maybe that's maybe that's all that was
on
clarence thomas's uh diet coke and maybe
we just said somebody's labradoodle that
got too close we're about to say they're
talking
yeah we got reggie just sent over
obama's unemployment rate yeah what was
the average for his uh
seven point eight that employee was high
when it took 7.8
and then it continued to get worse this
first year peaked at 10
then it dropped it didn't drop below 9
until two years after that so i don't
know that we have the average but my
guess is the average
and i know that that's unfair because he
came in and there was there was a crash
but uh compare that to covid where
everything shut down and how quickly
it's rebounded
and this is the difference between
barack obama and joe biden joe biden's
going to be coming into office after
the best economy we've ever had after a
changing of the republican coalition
and then gas prices are going to go up
then we're going to see
our standing in the world become more
subservient to nations like china we're
going to see
it's going to be carter on steroids if
joe biden were to actually win
so there's a silver lining either way
it's not at all the same thing as as
barack obama plus
none of the white guilt so remove that
lens and white guilt and historically
barack obama had a bad presidency
right and it's already removed because i
mean now you've added a lens of extra
whiteness with joe biden
but he got more votes legitimately more
votes in obama
more votes including a 170 year old
pennsylvania that's true it's only
somebody would have warned us about
mail-in ballots being
open to fraud why didn't anyone sound
the alarm if we only knew
if we only knew so here's another like
election update uh what are they hearing
no supreme
come on there's gonna be a legal court
uh challenge on cnn now you can bring up
their quarterback here so people can see
it
talking about oh there's gonna be a
challenge on obamacare again that'll be
perfect people will have seen drug
prices go down for the first time in
modern american history and their
premiums actually stabilize at some and
they'll go oh we're going back to the
obamacare era
good luck again that's assuming if joe
biden
actually get in he's not
i'm not just saying it i'm not just
saying it let me present you some more
we have some more election updates here
michigan so a detroit poll watcher
uh there was a story we had on this last
night then it was updated detroit poll
watcher testified that at 4 30 a.m
right after we broke the stream by the
way yeah 15 minutes after
uh on november 4th tens of thousands of
ballots were delivered from out of state
and unlike the other ballots these boxes
were brought in from uh the rear of the
room
is what she said okay and this lady said
i specifically noticed
every single ballot was for joe biden
yeah then there was another poll watcher
in detroit who testified that the ballot
didn't match the voter rolls
and uh that they were still being
counted we have audio from that poll
watchers so they're two
different poll watchers here's the
second one so what many poll challengers
were actually seeing
um was that when the ballots were
scanned
and it did not match a voter in the
electronic poll book and it did not
match a voter
in the supplemental paper poll book
which was provided due to michigan's law
that allows for same day registration
they were still allowing those ballots
to go through and be
counted and that is when the gop poll
challengers were issuing those
challenges
so they were either being ignored um
or kicked out all as well
uh speaking hit the notification bell by
the way if you are subscribed on the
youtube because subscriptions don't mean
a whole lot
uh notifications uh they just let you
know when things go up on this main
channel it's weekdays at 10 a.m we
broadcast live yeah we broadcast live
and
more people watching uh than cnn so
that's kind of fun yeah uh also do
consider joining mud club because that's
what supports us most of our things are
demonetized before i can even say d mana
it's already done
we didn't even get that far
livestrong.com club so that's michigan
yeah and so by the way if they had
brought a truckload of donald trump
votes in to help swing the state of
michigan we would be sounding the alarm
just as loudly there's
not there is no place for bringing in
ballots for people out of state
that don't ever help in this election
yeah exactly it didn't happen in any
case
we watched a consistent lead build
all night for donald trump in these
states and then consistent and
huge lead yeah and then the graph went
a complete change yeah like a little
like a little mario hop
yeah it did a little mario hop of fraud
so that's the thing yeah
and none of that happened with donald
trump no right yeah you can't find an
instance of
128 000 which they thought was okay over
there to washington it turns out it was
a typo but washington post at the time
just said nah that sounds about right
you can't find a single example of all
of a sudden
on unaccounted for coming in with no
poll watchers
15 20 or 100 000 votes for donald trump
just happening in the dead of night
you can't find it yeah rand paul tweeted
about this but he said uh
that the the government sent 1.1 million
people
coveted stimulus checks that were dead
dead people 1.1 million people who were
dead got stimulus checks you think how
many of those people you think voted but
how could they spend that money
if they're dead well it's expensive to
vote when you're dead there was a
a prime minister i can't remember who
actually uh had a bunch of dead voters
on his roles it's a famous story that we
learned i can't remember his name
history is very interesting and we had a
girl in our class who i swear like
raised her hand
yeah she said how could they all vote if
they were
dead she sounded like a valley girl in
canada
no that's no no that's exactly what she
said oh man
and then i remember later we were
talking about the native americans and
what they ate and stuff and the
mr holm i think was my history teacher
said you know some people find these
things a little bit odd because they
would eat squirrel rabbit anything they
could really find but you know compared
to americans who
you know they think it's weird in india
that we eat cow and she goes wait who
here eats cow
oh no and he said well are you a
vegetarian she said no
he said do you eat like burgers or
steaks oh my god that's cow
some really can't you can't this is a
real person yeah oh
well she's probably dead now let's be
honest oh come on just running the
numbers
just died of stupidity let's go to
georgia now we're taking you on a little
fraudulent vote journey yeah we should
have a little like road map you know
like when the muppets
just like a
yeah it's always muppets it's never like
indiana jones or the flying map thing no
it's the most i don't know
okay i guess i have a good reference i
like it i love it no it's great it's a
little more fun because everyone's
giving me crap good luck
not like i've been working hard enough
to enjoy some grace here yeah
guys they'll have to crap on me because
i watch them up at christmas carol too
early before thanksgiving you can go
screw yourself i do
start so georgia kyle becker uh formerly
i think he was at fox news uh pundit uh
the people's pundit project is where it
works
he was reporting in georgia that in
georgia 132
000 change of address red flags in
fulton
county so in one county these votes are
highly
likely and eligible to vote uh and have
moved
they've moved their location for source
meaning they probably don't live there
anymore
um and biden of course says that georgia
leads by 10 000 votes
this should be enough to be a game
changer here's what's interesting if you
look at that tweet can you bring it back
up right really quickly
right there it says this tweet is
disputed or whether this claim
this claim about election fraud is
disputed says twitter
by the way uh they still haven't
disputed do they dispute the new york
times and people saying oh no actually
pfizer was not uh
pfizer was never associated with
operation worksheet that's something
that you can
verifiably prove to be false right yeah
this is a statement someone makes
mike pence vice president said didn't
have to do with warp speed it just takes
a ri
just takes a couple of fingers even if
you have a guy with stubs he can just
you can he can just speak and spell into
his computer
and find out that it's true no dispute
on twitter
a dispute on this so i thought well you
know what i i know that kyle i i've
met kyle becker once or twice really um
i don't know him very well but
from what i understand he's done some
pretty good work um and i thought well
you know what he must be lying
oh because otherwise twitter yeah
twitter they wouldn't say so
and so i decided to it's a dispute and
then you click right on that little link
in dispute to read an article that fact
checks it and so again remember
the fact check should be on 130 2 000
change of addresses right yeah in
georgia because that's what he's
claiming
so i clicked on the dispute the fact
check and uh this is what it is it just
says
voter fraud of any kind is exceedingly
rare in the us i'll read you the whole
thing
election experts confirm this is the
fact check with ballot counting
continuing in the presidential race
being called for joe biden and experts
and officials say there has been no
evidence of widespread voter fraud in
the 2020 u.s election
the election process is secure and voter
fraud of any type is incredibly rare
according to the associated press and
reuters
remember they did the fake flotilla to
try to make it seem like the israelis
were uh were stabbing palestinians they
cropped the picture
oh yeah oh my gosh point is a piece of
[ __ ]
experts warn that the most interference
in us elections whether from foreign or
domestic players comes in the form of
misinformation campaigns many of which
are intended to create distrust
in the united states electoral process
but here's the thing i just read the
entire fact check right
there's no page two what about 130 32
000 votes in georgia
that's the claim right a fact check
is verifying that the fact that was
claimed is false you're checking the
fact
this could have been written 20 years
ago yeah uh election fraud is rare
i would agree it's generally rare
that's why this is a story that's why
kyle becker is saying
hey hey hey election fraud is and should
be rare
but we have a discrepancy 132 000 votes
i know it burns for you to say ap news
yeah it's like somebody reporting on the
french revolution and then somebody
fact-checking and saying
french revolutions almost never happened
it's true right yeah
very rare very rare in the history of
france it's only happened uh
one time one more fact check
yeah and every single article by the way
that you click on that has anything
about voter fraud or irregularities or
anything else is going to link to that
story and say
nothing to see here yeah and every
single one of them
and we're [ __ ] before we go
and why the like creepy passive voice
where it's like it is disputed
not by meaning twitter disputes it or
creditor doesn't want you to see this or
want you to
so doubt in it but if you were to put
this particular
right entity disputes it then you'd have
to check that entity
i just want an even i just want an even
playing field look we've talked about
michigan we've talked about pennsylvania
just today we've talked about georgia
we've given you the number of votes in
question
we've given you the precinct of where
the poll workers have worked
we've given you the quotes from the ceo
of pfizer himself
along with clips from president donald
trump and everyone who criticized him
along with the fact-checking articles
we have given you names numbers dates
precincts
it's sort of deluded just to say
receipts this is a whole lot more than
receipts this is a tax form
and they just say no this is an audit no
because they've been used to that for so
long yeah they've been
the legacy media has been used to for so
long just saying no
neil cavuto just said kaylee macklin he
goes up well there is there is strong
evidence
of voting regularities now yeah exactly
and then continue saying it but they
didn't they didn't account
here's what they haven't accounted for
what this is why i'm positive i want to
get to your point quarter blackout why
am i doing like donald trump
this is what they have in accounting
no they cut them off they didn't account
for us
meaning you more people watched
this than cavuto more people watched
this
than cnn more of you decided to be
informed
here because you know what when you were
watching our stream you knew
exactly what they were saying while they
were saying it and if it wasn't accurate
we gave you specifics
this is not specific this is just we
dispute it
okay that's that's like saying a duel
and you slap with the glove and the guy
pulls out a sword you're like i don't
know we're gonna fight
i just thought we said duel no we're
about to have a duel
dispute okay parlay all right well
here's the king oh [ __ ] i
didn't haven't thought this far what
about to say they're quarterback
mcilhenny said it she said if you don't
if you're not interested in
investigating these fraud allegations
then you are inviting in fraud right
exactly and that's why he cut her off
because she said
oh they're inviting in front that's what
she said yeah she's right
when you it's it's like telling a kid
that you're not going to watch them
it's like i believe in the house and by
the way if you have a kid who's really
annoying this is an easy trick you just
go
daddy's magical gun of mystery that
you're never supposed to touch is on the
table but i'm going to be gone for two
hours then you walk away
but the point is you're letting them
know there's no eye on them right as it
relates to elections
none at all yeah well and these are very
legitimate
claims a poll watcher not being allowed
in and things like that dead people
voting
i have watched unfortunately more hours
of cnn since the election than i care to
admit i'm sorry and i have not no you're
not
it's because of you i know i blame you
uh i have
seen before you go can i just go
uh there's no i haven't seen them say
yes that happened here's why and here's
why that's normal
legal a total you know nothing to see
kind of event and this person shouldn't
have been there in the first place he
didn't have the right forms
these votes were supposed to be counted
but they weren't none of that has
happened all it's been is
this exact link voter fraud in the
united states that's the line
everybody is saying voter fraud in cnn
you don't united
an interest over the fact that they they
wallpapered all the windows at joe lewis
arena yeah
right and i know it was it wasn't joe
lucas arena but you get my point
what is that doesn't even like raise an
eyebrow where'd you go to journalism
school
right and the word they keep using is
there's no evidence of widespread voters
right right exactly but that's what
we're talking about it can be
targeted in areas where it would make a
big difference which would be detroit
yeah philadelphia philadelphia the
places where we're saying it's happening
at the fox news headquarters they call
arizona
to demoralize people before the polls
right you know how much fraud you're not
going to hide
just investigating yeah exactly yeah do
you know how much you need you got
nothing to hide
you you need you need what 350 000 votes
across five six states no you don't need
that at most right now
at most you don't even need that in some
states you just need to say oh
10 000 of these no no i'm talking total
yeah i know but what i'm saying is
you're adding up the total you actually
don't arizona's separated by how many
votes what is it ten thousand i don't
remember it's not very
wisconsin is twenty thousand
pennsylvania is it's in the tens of
thousands
a hundred thousand votes just looking at
ones that can't be verified and again
election mail-in ballots were accepted
at a rate of
30 times that of 2016.
just that alone how did the mail-in
system get 30 times more effective i
remember right before this election you
were bitching about the post office
removing boxes
yeah and you're not saying that there
were 30 times the number of mail-in
ballots
it's that they were accepted at a third
time yeah
exactly which yeah which matters we're
so we're talking about a fraction of one
percent of the vote
in other words yes of course it's rare
previously if there were a hundred
thousand mail-in ballots
one thousand were actually let's say
right number one thousand accepted
versus this election thirty thousand
accepted
that much of a difference that much of a
difference and i'm not saying it's
thirty percent of total i'm just trying
to give you a number to give you some
scale here by the way
a hundred thousand ballots were rejected
in a california primary just to give you
an idea
in a primary yeah far fewer people vote
in the primary hundred thousand million
dollars were rejected that's a reason
there's a system of accountability let
me move on with georgia because people
can hear me um
rant about this until cows come home is
that what it is when do where do cows go
so here's another one oh uh georgia an
election official gabriel sterling
uh he's been clear by the way and
there's no interest in this from neil
cavuto or anyone over there at cnn
that they're going to be investigating
voter fraud
uh and he says that they will find dead
people voting and people voting twice
this is an election
official with uh a guy a
shopping mall santa miami now let me be
perfectly clear on another one cool
santa
we are going to find the tip that people
did illegally vote
that's going to happen there are going
to be double voters they're going to be
people who
shouldn't did not have the
qualifications of a registered voter to
vote in the state
that will be found that's first off that
the content is really important but i
know sign language that's not what he he
was just telling everyone to buy
fisherman's friend
that's all that's a very misleading
sneaky
i care about the integrity of our
elections though
and our translators yeah i think there's
a whole there's a whole episode of
seinfeld about double voters
[Laughter]
so now we go to pennsylvania again we
need to do an installment of each state
because i know it's time for sure
because we're talking about news as it
comes in but there's so many examples in
each individual state where you are way
past the threshold right of just look
i'm just saying hey we don't know
so in pennsylvania the trump campaign
they filed a lawsuit claiming that there
were different states here's what it is
different standards for voting in person
versus voting by mail in person you have
witnesses in person you have certain uh
yes well i know people to talk about
sharpie gate again the issue with
sharpies is that the instructions in
arizona that were sent out said do not
use a sharpie now sharpies may work
right yeah sure but why is a poll worker
handing you something
when the information says don't use it
right exactly it's almost like
we were told not to vaccinate brendan
but we said we'll give it a shot yeah
it was for science so the issue here is
that there are different standards for
voting in person this is the lawsuit
filed by the trump campaign versus the
mail-in voting
where uh there were none of those
standards and that it's unconstitutional
so in-person voters they had to meet a
lot of requirements that male and voters
didn't so this is uh from the trump
campaign and official statement says we
believe this two-track system results in
two constitutional violations
one the equal protection clause
violation and two elections and electors
clauses
violation again because how can you have
a standard
when you go in and vote i don't know
about you they asked me for my id yeah
every time uh and then they said don't
let anybody else touch your ballot
and then they said uh yours yeah that's
what they tell you don't let anyone else
touch your ballot but a very private
person
i could have sworn there was a joke
coming after that no there's no joke why
wouldn't you
[Laughter]
hold on cnn right now trump refuses to
concede amid
unfounded claims of voter fraud
unfounded
in a white background unfounded every
time why do they keep putting on this
like putting a guy in a green screen
suit
in a swamp result they can prove as
fraudulent
but one week after election day they
have offered no
proof not in pennsylvania oh geez not in
georgia what are you talking about
any place on the map that shows joe
biden in georgia
sir 76 million we have affidavits sworn
affidavits we have here
personally hundreds hundreds of dead
voters yeah
just here just us doing our own
investigation in michigan pennsylvania
hundreds of dead voters six thousand
votes switch glitches
people who didn't win who then all of a
sudden were winning poll workers not
being allowed in
tens of thousands of votes that
absolutely came in after the deadline
they just this is just what they do no
proof well hold on a second
did you run all of mac and ninny's press
conference did you
yeah it's just this is my problem with
fox news it's just like
cnn no evidence they're all just going
out with this message yeah and like i
said
128 000 votes found overnight for biden
right in michigan
this is what happened it turned out to
be a typo whatever that guy's name was
at washington post i always forget his
name phillip
phillip bump in our in direct messaging
that had taken place
said well it's a biden county there is
no level of voter fraud that they would
investigate
right when it was 128 000 that couldn't
be physically possible
and they later fixed because it was a
typo washington post said
no tomfoolery here yeah and that's why
right now they're saying no evidence
there is absolutely evidence of voting
irregularities and i will say it now i
don't care if i get banned
outright fraud in some instances now the
fraud may only be a few thousand
granted the irregularities hundreds of
thousands absolutely if not millions
there is absolutely evidence you just
make sure that people don't see because
if we provide the evidence
we say hey here's a list of several
thousand dead people voting
including 170 year olds from a county in
pennsylvania you say this is disputed
and you run us to the ap dispute that
says election fraud is rare
we agree it's rare that's why it pisses
us off so much right exactly and by the
way irregularities mean states
not following their own laws right
states circumventing their
own laws yeah to allow votes to come in
past deadlines and that's one of the
cases that she made if cavuto had
listened for 30 more seconds right
that the the supreme court said no the
legislature can't decide this which is
where the power resides we're going to
decide the
votes can come in and you don't have to
show id you don't have to have a
signature it doesn't even have to have a
postmark on it if you find a ballot on
the floor
count it right that's exactly what the
rules say yeah go ahead
i was going to say cnn if you want some
credibility what you do is you present
your opponent's
strongest argument and then you show why
it's wrong
but they quit a bit but but they can't
do that
you see that again credibility
credibility credit bill
credit bill yeah credibility like you
can get credit
but they can't do it they can't show the
other person if it's a loan that you
guaranteed can't pay
right and that makes you a predator
this is why when people say why some
this defeatism that comes from concern
what i hate is this bar that is set that
conservatives
set for themselves when they expect none
from the left
like for some their conservatives now
saying well good luck proving the course
listen there is so much evidence right
now
it is so overwhelming for you to set a
bar
meaning it has to be outright every
single vote for biden is fraught
for people to keep up the fight i'm
sorry you're not you're not on this team
and like i said it very well may be
possible that we look into these
hundreds of thousands of voting
irregularities and anomalies
and maybe joe biden does win when that's
the case
fine but we haven't and we have never
had
these kinds of irregularities let me
give you some examples of what we've
never had
and we've gone through these several
times i've just gone through some here
but let's not go through the numbers
because there's hundreds of thousands
what have we never had before
unrequested mail-in ballots that's never
happened before so that's a problem
what have we never had before this level
of acceptance of maryland ballots
30 times the rate we've never had that
before what have we never had before
ballots that only voted for joe biden
and left the rest blank we've never had
that before
what have we never had before people
calling states before all the votes were
in and military ballots not coming in in
time
we've never had that before what have we
never had before pol poll watchers not
being allowed to watch not being allowed
entry that's never happened before
what have we never happened before
people plastering the voting precincts
with bristol boards and papers so that
people could not look in
that's never happened before you know
what else has never happened before when
a press secretary whose job it is to
inform the press as to
all these anomalies that are taking
place you cut it off before she can list
them
none of those things have ever happened
before right also dead people but that
has happened before
because the democratic party exists but
not yeah
to this level when you add all of those
up those things have never happened
before in any other election
hundreds of thousands yeah exactly oh
also i even forgot the biggest one
one's coming in after the election
deadline yeah coming in after 8pm just
throw
not only that but then being tossed in
with the others so you can't track them
yeah none of those things have what else
have we never had happened before too
a computer software glitch 6 000 votes i
don't know that we've ever had happen
before
a digital software glitch that had a
republican losing and then flipped and
he won
none of these things have happened
before
and why why on youtube is the fact check
not from
real clear politics who still hasn't
called the race as far as i know
yeah they hadn't this morning when i
looked right it's all it's from the ap
so anytime a video is called it's not
over yet or something like that michael
knowles released a video we released a
video with a similar title
always that same fact check for every
news piece about the election
um and it isn't over yeah and i don't
know but
the ap amendment oh they're the ones who
determine
yeah yeah yeah it's like super delegates
those facts i feel so bad about my
education
yeah well a minute ago the lower third
said that you know trump refuses to
concede the election and then then the
guy was talking about you know five days
a week late or whatever
i'm like this is basically like you
saying on october 28th
donald trump refuses to concede the
election even though he's trailing in
the polls like
it's not done yet why would why would he
concede before he told us it wouldn't be
done for a month
since right you had your fact checking
prepared if donald trump claimed victory
within the week let's keep that in truth
let's keep that in
check here it's still within the week
you had that ready
like a nuclear option a button if donald
trump claimed victory
within the week of the election because
you guys told us it would take months
yeah and now you're saying it's clear we
know we don't even have all the votes in
yet
some some places just stop counting for
days and then some places just had jumps
to hundreds of thousands
at the witching hour i took an hour and
a half and by the way i don't want to
lie
i took an hour and 20 minute nap in a
hammock woke up
and the country was [ __ ]
but you know you know in my life you
know
like the thing that's scaring cnn their
lower third right now is
that mcconnell and top republicans back
trump's refusal to concede
right that's really good news for us
that's really good when i see
the people who are on this ted cruz rand
paul bill barr mcconnell
that's a that's quite a coalition they
they this is
yeah these are not just people who look
at the like we look at them
the graph and go like well that looks a
little weird that it just jumped up
right but these are people who are
actually and rudy giuliani i forgot to
mention him right yeah just all of this
incredible information that they have
and we are just
with the information available publicly
able to see something's off and they
agree
ted cruz is very careful ted cruz was
the most i think even the person was the
head of the
harvard law review said that he was
probably one of the most annoying and
most skilled students that he ever had
skills yes the head of harvard law
review when barack obama
or the person who was i don't know if it
was the dean because
actually barack obama was the head of
the harvard law review but there's
someone above that maybe it was their
professor
uh when you asked him about barack obama
he said
yeah he was there i think it was the
only time he's never published ted cruz
was like a national level debate
champion people need to understand this
doesn't mean he's dorky sure
but yeah the first rule of being a
lawyer
he's a lawyer is don't ask a question
you don't already know the answer to
i guarantee you having spent and you
know tickers have been on the show maybe
a dozen times we've had ron paul on
quite a bit
rand paul sorry on quite a bit um ted
cruz
would not go in just for some twitter
traffic ted cruz would not go in on this
unless he knows that there is something
there
keep that in mind rand paul ted cruz
these are not people
who are unreasonable who act outside the
boundaries of the law these were people
who were trying to safeguard our
constitutional republic
before the election and are right now
saying that it's compromised
it is amazing to me that we have a media
who falsely created this
russia collusion narrative right there
was no proof never admitted it by the
way
and now they say but elections are
impenetrable the election process is
impenetrable their defense
is impetuous and they're going to make
orphans of your children the point is
[Applause]
now there's no way anyone could affect
the elections certainly not
actual poll workers who are stopping the
other pole watchers like hooper
humperdinck
yeah exactly well and you know if you
want if you're on the left right now and
you want donald trump to leave
office peacefully what is the very best
thing that you can do
open everything up and say you think
there's irregularities you think there's
fraud
let's dive into it so that when that
transition comes he will walk out of
this office peacefully if you really are
scared he's just going to stay in office
and not leave
right that's exactly what you would do
unless you were afraid that something is
there that will be found out they could
give him no excuse
yeah they could if they were to open
things up and everything was legit like
okay well i have no excuse see how crazy
this guy is claiming there's fraud look
nothing to see everything's open because
i tell you what i
i always used to say this president
obama and i tried to say president trump
and every now and then you say okay
trump
you'll see trump biden because you know
you have to save words you have to
breathe when you speak
but i always said listen he is my
president with president obama uh he's
my president i always hate when people
just said bush
so president obama that being said
president obama sucks balls at his job
i want to be able to uh i don't want to
i don't want to fight a ghost
right i want to know that i am
actually resisting remember that the
resistance and meet the new resistance
it's all of a sudden the resistance
isn't cool to the left
it's disruptive despite it being not
mostly peaceful entirely peaceful
i don't want to fight a ghost i don't
want to i don't want to be grabbing a
bar of soap
i want to know beyond any shadow of a
doubt that joe biden is president of the
united states if that's what happens
i want to know beyond any shadow of a
doubt that the american people chose him
and that there was
no shenaniga that there were no
shenanigans afoot that's what you should
want to listen
if you're going to talk about healing in
this country and i know what they're
going to try and say
they will try and say well you know what
the thing is donald trump is just
bringing up that's what they're trying
to do bogus claims no no no no
i just walked you through ten examples
of anomalies that have never occurred in
a modern american election
there is more than enough reason
certainly more than uh the reason you
had which was three thousand ads to the
tune of ten thousand dollars from some
guy with a laptop in russia okay
facebook ads there is more than enough
reason
to call not only the votes are already
in question to investigate them
to read them you can if you if you pull
this off
you can't even tell kids that reading is
good for them because you refuse to do
it here
they're not going to buy it from you
like hey hey you need to read more yeah
but mom you refuse to read the ballots
don't wait up [ __ ] they're not going to
trust you
i want to be able to say that's my
president exactly i don't think he's
very good at his job
president joe biden yeah and spend the
next four years you should want to be
able to say the same thing yeah we got
to spend the next four years trying to
get somebody who can go into that office
and do a great job
instead of joe biden if that happens to
be the case we want
fair elections period right i don't want
even if i think donald trump is the
savior
come back and people in this country
vote for somebody else
they have that right they have the right
to be wrong that's all we're asking for
nothing more people vote listen people
voted to free barabbas
crazier things have happened i know
jesus whoa that was a vote yeah that's
true
it was it was barabbas
[Music]
you know barabbas sniffs kids
that wasn't and that's not the worst of
that what is that is that that's
sniffs beyond our children and our
children's children
yeah well they are something i'll gibson
[Laughter]
gibson goes listen i knew it
don't bring don't don't speak of me out
of turn because you know i don't like
you i don't want you to talk about that
okay all right mal gibson go to trader
joe's i love their two canoes we do too
okay common ground good all right
before we actually final story it says
on a little bit of a lighter note oh
wait they're talking about bill barr
please hold on really quickly
well if true could potentially impact
the outcome
as well he's just doing this to keep the
president happy and even bill barr knows
there's no there there
uh which is it look at do you see what
that is attributing
john i think the uh the memo that bill
barr issued yesterday
sort of ended a very awkward silence
from
the justice department for days and days
the president his lawyers his campaign
have been holding press conferences
doing filing frivolous lawsuits really
uh claiming that there was this massive
fraud while providing no evidence
of such massive fraud that would make a
difference here's the section
you have to be a [ __ ] to watch cnn let
me tell you what yeah
why are we doing it a press conference
went on when you're talking about this
kelly mcilhenny or uh kelly mcinerney or
you're talking about rudy giuliani right
these press conferences went on for some
of them 20 minutes 40 minutes i don't
have it in front of me you can fact
check me maybe i'm wrong but they went
on for a substantial amount of time and
there were many different people who
spoke
yeah including uh elected officials
including local representatives
including poll watchers including
volunteers
and they all brought forward specific
evidence with numbers
yeah so you just say no evidence well on
a second
just say the evidence they bro the very
thin evidence they brought forward that
you know
132 000 people in georgia whose
residence may not be valid they brought
forth very thin evidence
with verified obituaries with thousands
of people who voted mail-in ballots and
obituaries very very thin evidence
just do that but instead they've never
covered it and they just tell you no
evidence
why again no st this is why they won't
this is why they won't have me unseen
and we've had
i used to appear on hln yeah and seeing
it you know what once they started
actually having receipts they stopped
they stopped if i were unseen and i
would say huh what about the 132
000 in georgia that right now are being
investigated what
what i would say hey what about the 8
000 military ballots that were on their
way in do we know what happened with
those huh
what hey how many ballots were received
in pennsylvania after 8 p.m on election
night and
that's actually unconstitutional they
have to be tossed out well i don't know
and hey were those actually blended in
with votes that came in before 8 pm so
that it couldn't be uh they couldn't be
differentiated because that's also
against the law
well i don't know i don't know what
about the 128 000 vote typo that you
didn't call anybody on until the people
themselves who made the typo came out
and said sorry are bad
sorry that [ __ ] listen what about
any they give you no specifics watch
all morning and fox news 2 screw those
guys
screw those when they just say there's
no evidence no evidence
none look we've given you specifics
maybe
maybe they'll look into the 132 000
change of address red flags in fulton
county and say
oh those people actually uh they just uh
they moved over a county over and we're
fine yeah
who do you think has a better standard
of evidence attorney general bill barr
or this guy on cnn and what do they do
they just say well bill barr is clearly
just trying to keep the president happy
yeah because it's not like bill barr
sent your whole world tumbling down
several times before right right yeah
gupta
yeah and are they going to say the same
thing about ted cruz ted cruz is not
some trump sycophant
right yeah yeah same with rand paul they
both debated him
they both had plenty of issues chris's
dad of killing jfk right
right yeah exactly and megan kelly right
now who obviously doesn't get a
christmas card from donald trump is
still saying you got to let this process
play out this process play out and
you see how the coordinated effort right
you're seeing it with big tech everybody
is saying voter fraud doesn't exist and
these claims are baseless
base every single time they reference
these claims unfounded
voter fraud claims unfounded every
single time but every single person
actually referenced them specifically
they just say in general yeah
by the way they said unfounded when
donald trump said what is this
again 120 what's the name of that guy
over there at washington post
um philip bump in private messages again
we can bring this up for you it was sent
him i hope that i've have i described
this clearly enough for people
on earth 128 000 votes found for
zero by the way overnight to zero it's
128 to zero 128 biden with
zero trump zero trump happened overnight
in the dead of night
and at this point donald trump said hey
what is this and that was marked as a
disputed claim
yeah no one ever thought it's not even
possible for there to be that many votes
for biden let alone
zero for trump and i mean total i'm not
even talking about the ratio which by
the way is why they disable comments on
a lot of cnn yeah
you don't want to get ratio because
guess what we have a team
of people who will ratio the hell out of
you not to bully you but because you lie
we ratio people who lie but i'm talking
about 128 000 votes
not the ratio that there were zero trump
it's not
possible trump asking the question yeah
what is happening here
fact checked disputed washington post
saying
what's complicated and then a few hours
later oh it's a typo
yeah isn't it the news's job to figure
out a typo
yeah if you can dispute look right now
if i were just to say this nobody said
anything because i want no context
four million dead voters there were four
million dead voters in michigan
period of the votes in michigan four
million of them were from dead people
stop
no one if i said that seriously no one
would go
wait that's not possible that's exactly
what happened that's exactly what
[ __ ] happened and no one cared no one
cared and then later i came out and said
sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry did i say four
million i meant four
[Laughter]
but first four hours or three hours or
whatever it is
no one said anything they'd look they'd
lock me away from social media forever
that's what happened well it's worse
than that they didn't just not say
anything
they carried the water for it and said
it's totally possible totally normal
yeah has any vote dump in history right
i don't care
you're counting the votes and you're
saying all right we got another 150 000
votes they go this guy this guy has any
one of those dumps in history come back
one hundred percent for one person and
zero percent
and that's what's so scary is they
carried the water at this point the
media is carrying each other's water
oh yeah but now we could enter into a
realm if this is allowed to stand and
this is why we will continue fighting
they will be carrying
the government's water think about that
for a second right now their fight is
against shows like this that do better
than them
right daily wire and a lot of in blaze
and all kinds of
not even alternative media because it's
more consumed media than theirs
yeah right so right now they're carrying
water to try and silence us and fact
check us but what do you think is going
to happen when joe biden says
120 something of the equivalent 128 000
votes for me or what about when joe
biden says actually that wasn't uh
donald trump's facing that was my
vaccine the media's gonna go look joe
biden's vaccine
that's propaganda right and the media is
trying to say that this is a battle that
has been won and it's been won
in the halls of the media whereas trump
is saying no this is a battle that needs
to be fought in the courts
right and he's right yeah and they're
wrong it's the wrong battlefield
they're trying to decide that they are
the battlefield and there's a reason
that the courts exist because they are
supposed to be a safeguard for the
people
not the media right right there is no
accountability for them this is the same
media who said jesse smallett had bleach
port on him
and was had someone a news put over his
neck and it was a shoelace
this is the same media by the way that
nick sandman was uh
harassing a native american when it was
really just some crackhead
banging a calf skin drum and the kid was
the kid was just uncomfortable
yeah and then they also said this is a
frivolous lot that's what they're just
right now right now just to give you an
idea
the same network that said donald trump
is filing frivolous
lawsuits had to pay they had to pay
several of their lifetime salaries to
nick sandman for lying
remember brian stealth are saying this
for nuisance money
really hundreds of thousands of dollars
cnn nuisance money so these are the same
people who said it was frivolous when
they slandered a kid
and they lost and now they're trying to
say it about bill barr
these are these are the same people who
said frivolous nick's nick sandman
lawsuit lost hundreds of thousands of
dollars
legitimate russia and bill barr said
nope
yeah yeah but trust them all as well
what do you think about that joe lewis i
just noticed that he moved his head a
little bit
he's sleeping joe lewis do you have any
thoughts should i talk about cardi b
oh gosh please no should i talk about
cardi b joe lewis
okay he's not a fan so uh cardi b
actually teased her new uh signature
reeboks uh with this promotional image
who don't oh my god
can we have can we dispute that yeah
she totally won this claim is under
under review
yeah little icon under there uh i i
don't really get the appeal uh but she
also
uh there's also uh this isn't the only
ad that she has i don't get the appeal
but um i guess it's just a matter of
taste because some people love her
[Music]
oh what a night ah beautiful
nothing like navigating under the stars
i'll say by the foam
oh it's like a painting wait
do you hear that here what is
that's the most beautiful sound my ears
have ever heard
no no i can't call patrick no
hey what's happening we lost another one
[Music]
future america disgusting take
everything you don't like now and remove
the safeguards and add dementia
so uh listen for people this is the
first time we're doing it since the
election streams because we've made
everything uh free but
i think you've gotten about an hour and
a half of content right now there's
gonna be about another
30 40 minutes with manny the art critic
uh we're going to be creating
we're gonna have him criticize and
critiquing critiquing what what is it
between critiquing and criticizing you
know we'll talk about it behind the pit
ball because uh
wade is very affected and you know he's
a little bit of a snobby prick but i
love him
so we'll be talking about that
difference and taking your chats
exclusively
mug club so that's one of the perks you
get to chat with us because we know
you're not so much of a security threat
uh we are going to go now exclusively to
mug club youtube
thank you dispute this video all you
want we still say piss off